The story of Halacame from
a lot of lived experience.
I was living with my family,
and I started to recollect
these memories
of, like, what it was like
to grow up in that household.
I think you need to be a little
more understanding about Mom.
She's overprotective.
The dynamic in my household
was not something I got
to see onscreen,
so I put all these little
script vignettes together
and that was the basis
ofHala.
Because this is pretty much
Minh's story,
I knew that it would be
authentic,
and it would be very powerful.
I'm not sure why I write.
I've said everything
I want to say.
There must be
something you wanna say
that nobody's already said.
Hala doesn't quite have
it all together.
She's still figuring it out.
She's gonna make mistakes.
She's a teenage girl,
and we need to normalize that.
-And you're not scared?
-Are you?
Maybe.
Even though she's from
a Muslim family,
it is a movie that a lot
of people can relate to.
I'm sorry.
For young women, in particular,
it's important to feel like
you can have your own agency
and go on the search
for identity
without having to abandon
your culture or your faith.
You said that I could tell you
if something was going on.
Something's going on.
We might have cultural
differences,
but in actuality,
there are more things
that make us similar
than different.
And this movie is really
a beautiful example of that.